[Music]
so thank you guys for coming out this is
strategy session with Jonathan shrunk
it's been a while since we've done one
of these classes so it feels good to get
back into it again
so thanks everybody for coming out
tonight and tonight I thought for our
theme I want to look at a couple
examples I just have some puzzles those
seem to be popular so I got some puzzles
and we're going to talk about
simplifying into a winning endgame so a
lot of times in chess there's a very
important decision whenever the last
pieces are going to come off the board
and you're going to get into a King and
pawn ending so if we look over here at
the board what is the question that
White's should be asking himself it's
Luke McShane in this position I mean
what is the question
yeah can we fact so we're about to trade
the last piece but before we do it we
need to calculate and evaluate this
position for example if this draws or
loses then you're just making a big
mistake giving your work away you should
keep it on because you still have
winning chances so the question becomes
if we sacrifice on f7 will we win so I'm
going to give you guys a minute this is
going to be one of those those
calculating puzzle type classes I know
the audience has had sort of a while
here so maybe people have already come
up with it so I hope you do want to
pause your videos and see if you can
calculate it and try to go as deep as
you can and then I'll ask you guys what
the evaluation is of this position you
got it all ready
easy not easy not easy okay Jesus at the
core moves the King so I can shed
yeah so we can sack and then what are we
going to do we need to make sure we we
follow up correctly okay so some people
are thinking after we sack King to f4
came to d5 has been suggested
so probably yeah probably going this way
is not right it's got to probably be one
of those two looms but it let's see how
far you can go yeah so that's the first
basic trick we'll just show the basic
trick here you have to go to d5 on e5
black gets the opposition and should
easily draw okay so if we take we're
going to play King d5 with the idea that
if he plays came to e7 we play King to
e5 and now it's his turn so we should be
able to muscle our way in is that enough
let's see how far you can go and try to
yes we'll see how far you can go and see
when white eventually wins that pawn
where's the black king going to be
holy g8 or h8 yeah yeah so if you
calculate it let's imagine now our king
wins this pawn on g6 and the opponent
then plays King to g8 is that a win and
if so do you see the move so what if it
is opposition but it's White's turn why
does a king on g6 black of the King on
g8 and now white is forced to move is it
still in okay you know a lot of heads
nodding yes you don't think so okay and
that's in this position you'd better
make sure you're certain
otherwise you should just play some
random move and keep your rook on the
board yeah maybe King f4 is fine maybe
some gets Gang of Four is the only other
real move
and so all too often people they sit and
they calculate on like every move for a
long time and I've noticed in a lot of
like beginner games so when I like teach
students and stuff a lot of times they
get to this decision where they're going
to trade the very last piece but they
don't really think of the consequence
because something very real is going to
happen it's now the result is just like
determined that's a win a loss or a draw
and it's like rather easy it's just a
technical task of calculating it so
let's go ahead and get to the position
that we're talking about so if you're
still thinking at home you can pause at
this moment but we're going to put on
the board this position kingi five very
important and now if they go here we get
the opposition and black is forced to go
this way to protect this pawn and we can
slowly but surely yeah wherever we go
there's a couple different ways we could
get here we should be able to muscle our
way in and reach this position by force
so is this a draw is it a win or a draw
it's a win we got to draw off win two
for draw one for win okay so do we see
the winning move if you think it's a win
have you calculated the win yeah please
yeah six okay and right so King f6 has
been suggested there's really only two
reasonable moves you gotta keep your
king advanced if you run back black will
advance okay so you're thinking King f6
slims but what do you do on King h7 king
of seven okay you think this is the
winner
stalemate this is actually a draw so
King f6 is a draw which leaves us with
King h6
well if you run away we play King page
seven you play here g6 g7 the King is
flushed out in white wins so so it is a
win you do have to find King to h6 so a
big congrats to anyone who from the very
start in this position was able to
identify that it is a win and hopefully
you found King h6
in that position because I think that
was the tough part for the high rated
players but this actually is a win so
why did go on to win my resignation was
like somewhere around here I think we
need to have been the night they just
agreed because the true Grand Master's
playing yeah yeah two grandmasters they
get it ok now I want to show another
where did it go
another example of a very similar
endgame let's see this how do I respond
to so huge
ok this is the game Nigel short versus
ivan chip Aronoff from 2008 and it is
white to move because why doesn't check
and now i'll give you guys a minute and
then I'll kind of ask you what's what's
sort of the general question that we
should be asking in this position do we
have a way to liquidate and if we we do
is it'll win so again we're up in
exchange but now there's a couple more
pieces so it's slightly more complicated
yeah so we have this this sort of idea
but we got to make sure we play accurate
so these ideas are in the position we
can trade everything but notice if you
do this right away let's all you out
yeah if you do it right away
yeah one problem is if you go here
it's different now
so it's slightly different so let's be
careful I'm not going to say that's
that's right or wrong so let's just be
careful here let's try to be accurate
you pretty much have to take the night I
mean I was you're dropping your pond and
then King takes his forced because the
bishops pinned this will win for white
okay but it's just a gut feeling right
even your calculation we need a waiting
loop okay do we have one after we
exchange the King takes because the
rotor goes somewhere sure it will go
anywhere I want okay
kingi for and then I'll okay yeah that's
just a rumor but it doesn't work so I
don't think it let you look them so
quickly because the king is talking talk
about it they may look that rich in
place noise Bishop takes Knight jerk ah
yes this is an interesting nuance ah
okay so we're looking at Bishop f6 King
f6 g5 King back rook takes e7 takes and
now look we get the position from my leg
in so this is actually the correct
solution and I was played and here
resigns because now we have the
opposition and black has to go this way
and it's the same position from before
okay
so there's all these little nuances in
all these kinds of positions there's all
you know little subtle moves here and
there and that can make them really hard
to evaluate and let's look at another
example so this will be slightly
different in this position it's white to
move and we really are gonna have to pay
a lot of attention to all the little
nuances in these positions so in this
there's a lot more puns how incredibly
hard to calculate I'll give you guys a
minute now to it's white to move and
that's what yeah is it wait to win draw
well so what is the question I guess I
can ask you now black lumps yes this is
the question right what about rook c6
and then hopefully we go in here and I
take all that so that's the question
rook c6 what's the evaluation so do take
your time this is a little more
complicated
yeah so it does look right Rick c6 rook
c5 exbc six kings you fix King me five
and that should just be a simple win
should be right you can put it on the
board just for fun no so this is winning
so but black doesn't have to play that
way there's make sure you look at all of
the options okay
okay so if you play rough see fix I have
to think I mean otherwise I'll lose your
work okay and you take back on c6 with a
pawn
now it's blacks turn we don't have to
take the pawn right away well do I have
a defense or not I mean that's the
question
if f4 works that's an interesting idea
therefore it takes yeah so another thing
yeah if you're just left with just a rip
on sometimes it's it's tough you know if
we only have this guy then blacks option
becomes can I run into the corner in
time so we have a lot of the ideas but
now we're gonna have to put it all
together nice all right the calculation
part is the hard part the general vague
ideas those come a little more naturally
but the question is okay because they
right yeah you can't take right away
your ideas up for right away no fun if
white doesn't take the F for pawn versus
D pawn okay and you're looking at the
move f4 okay let's do y versus pawn this
one yeah okay also I can you have they
just take but no so he takes and then
wipe it off or okay yeah I don't see you
winning this though oh I don't see you
winning this one h4 is definitely a very
useful move for white so if rook c6
doesn't win for sure you should just
play h4 that's just a useful move
gaining more space and a lot of these
ideas white is a little bit closer to
the cleaning square so for sure that
that's a move that is very strong
I'm gonna say it might be right it might
be wrong I'm I've yet to say I just want
to know the evaluation what happens is
this what happens because if it wins
then I'll just play that I win looks
like an easy win Thursday there is a
resource blackheads that we've missed
that the black has so we have to notice
that first before we can evaluate
whether it's a win or a draw here
rook c6 rook c6 PC six black to move
right now perhaps you don't want to
trade
you'd only train if you think it's a win
now as you play Age 4 which is probably
the best move in the position which is a
big hint to help spur the class along
you should yeah that's move smoothly but
why does this not win this is actually a
draw okay we have to take it's not the
up floor idea like as another move here
and this is why these are really tricky
it's you know not easy to see because my
next move I mean I'm going to go here
force you away and I'm running in but as
I've been kind of said if we can get it
down to just this guy maybe we can take
this guy here and then run to the corner
classic three pawns in a row right so
black plays here gets three pawns in a
row yeah and yeah I mean yeah there is
that Norton that breakthrough if it's
three in a row versus 3 in a row there's
a break for Lydia for eg for it can't be
g4 yeah because that's a legal oh it
can't be g5 alright I go here right I
mean 4c way ok you have to take that
one three five and then at four right so
you go up four F four you have to take
yeah I mean you can't give me this
pather here have to take and then be
careful Mike doesn't have to take well
so if you don't take you're saying no
you're going to get over here somehow
what I just go here you are okay so let
me go here first
I guess because attacks that thing all
right let me go here all right yeah it
looks like I win yay you don't have to
take but not taking losses so in a way
you have to take all right now do I make
it in time just like make it to the
corner in time Oh No
so on the lighthouse light has to go
here don't like I have to go here don't
take the fun right away yeah it is
tricky yeah so obviously so here and
draw and but you also can not not do
that also if you go here I can go here
or I can push either way and you're
going to have to go this way eventually
so it's actually a draw and it's due to
this you know tricky move in this
position I mean congrats if after rook
c6 you could already see this idea of g5
and f4 and then making it into the
corner that's why these are a really
tricky and so as I stated I mean just
move h4 is very strong
what nut might not be winning but it's
like black now has to like go back or
make some other move interesting is
this now loses now this now this check
is too strong you don't have this idea
anymore and once you have to go get this
guy my king doesn't stroll in and get
the guys is always to always win before
the endgame and you'll never have to
calculate this kind of position that is
that's definitely the point of this
whole lecture yeah you hit it right on
it does yes h4 I mean I just have to
like go back one tricky thing is it's
also hard for me to advance because
anywhere I go you have like a rook check
and then the rook goes back to b6
but for sure white is for choice now and
yes I mean this is this is tricky so you
have to make sure you see all the right
defenses here so let's go to another one
yeah you can fake the openings for the
endgame it's just straight calculation
okay
so this position is white to move so
again I'll give you guys a little time
and that's home you may want to pause
just to assess the position but first
what is the question can we take on e5
is that a win is it a draw what's going
on so that's the first thing we're going
to look at in all this one's my favorite
so take some time because I like it
personally now I've shown this to a
couple people today and they said this
is by far not the hardest that one I
just showed you way harder but it's my
favorite so take your time so rookie 5
we don't have to take right away
we can play King up 6 ok that's very
good to know and then we have to take it
because you're attacking it twice ok so
I have to take you play King take c6
so we yes we get this position here's
the black King here's the white King
just like to move so it becomes is it a
win pawn to b5 yeah so with the King on
e6 and the waiking on an e4
b5 yeah very good that wins that's the
claim at least
wasn't that hard
well you haven't solved it yet actually
doesn't win mm doesn't win let's prevent
the crack line okay so we take King f6
and now we got a trade and the King goes
to e6 you play b5 now it's blacks turn
and it's not over the puzzle is not over
now it's black to move so it's not gonna
take it
nope now gonna take it bring the King
over so if you take I can go to the
corner okay super strengthen you push
do not push well I mean okay if you
don't put I mean if you move your king
over
well now I'm taking and I'm going to be
in time to get to the corner also I can
just run to the corner right away and
there's this interesting fortress idea
the idea is if you play b6 it's actually
a fortress even though you're up upon my
king goes here and goes like this and
I'll give you a million moves how are
you going to break through this so
that's why I think this is quite clever
you're up upon so you just like art I
win
two on one but it's a rare case so
there's actually a little fortress here
and black just a little bit and you
never break through so that's why I like
that one because I like that little
fortress idea so the answer to the
question is it's a draw if you take it's
a draw so you look for another move and
the move played in the game wins very
easily just the move b5 a play b5 first
yep in the game King to f6 if you take
now we can take here and then we get in
time to get the pawn and we're queening
so we win which is why in the game King
a six was tried but now white one rather
simply by just bringing this rook over
here winning the pond
ny1 so it's very important I mean it's
it just seems so natural right I'm just
going to take the pawn to one one should
be a slam dunk but it's not it's not
these are really tricky
sano time this will do one more this one
I showed this one before I don't even
remember this one so let's do this one
to finish it off maybe maybe I can
figure it out all right so it would
appear that is in check
leading me to believe it's black to move
so suspicion I have black isn't trick so
I flipped it I flipped it okay so here's
here's h8 you say one so these guys are
going like this we're going like this
it's important to draw these arrows and
this guy moves like up and down and oh
yeah I'm not off so I'm used to teaching
my my 4 year old so I have to slipped it
back into that mode ok black is in check
and before I give you guys a minute
to really think about it what is what's
the question yeah so we basically have
two options either we take or we move
our king out of the way let's say King
just c7 and I think I know the answer on
the genius
I prepared this lecture like months and
months and months ago good thing I was
able to figure it out again you don't
have to take the pawn right you can play
King to c7 so I actually have to analyze
both variations King 7 and what ok it's
worth a look I assume I just take on
that five-o King e7 I just taken them up
upon let's just cheat because you know
Thursdays you got to just cheat so it
does say here
yeah it's equal so that's that's
possible you do want to do something to
protect your pond so we're kind of
getting the idea I mean black is just
probably going to lose upon so we are
looking to draw really it's unlike
League like it's going to win because
we're going to lose upon whether we take
or not you know things can get exchanged
and pieces could get taken and we're
probably gonna be down so it's very
unlikely that we're going to win so we
also got to be careful not to lose right
I mean sometimes in chess you got it not
lose okay sometimes you're trying to
drop thank you and get there to kick the
F bones all over to the H files indicate
after the King takes right you're going
to try to get what palm to where you're
try to get your king to here is Blackey
a great play goes off okay after some
trades the black king might want to try
to run into the corner okay this is very
very true do not put a move yeah so do
we have time to trade and then make it
to the corner
so yeah you got a count yeah
and yeah sometimes it's difficult even
want to super straightforward in force
force force you know just this ability
to see six seven eight moves into the
future can be tough because it's you
gotta go do that sometimes you got to
get your fingers involved to just yeah
it gets harder with age well that's also
why these are good just for improving
your calculation because if you can see
eight nine ten moves in a row when it
shows super super forced and straight
forward it can make and really help a
lot that's why these endgame puzzles are
actually usually some of the hardest
imagine if I actually take a really hard
puzzles and we all be in trouble
wait so you're looking at this right I
mean this is the first question let's
analyze this first okay we got to think
of our whites move here carefully
so if you're white here now I mean
what's the first thing you want to
calculate if you want to win simply rook
takes right let's trade rooks and then
do I win that becomes the question now
white should be asking themselves you're
at least won't lose yeah why won't lose
but yes this is also an option but let's
look at the straight forward move
because this was played in the game and
black resigned giving an indication
2,500 verse 2400 why did he resign
though okay I have to take the rook my
king goes here so you you have some
options here those black I can run just
straight forward hopefully I make it I
also could try h4 maybe making this guy
an outside pun so if King D sexless just
straight forward am I going to make it
and wins this is the wind point so
slightly more interesting is h4 and I
have to take it I can't let you Queen
first but now you didn't make it it's
over had that a game just looking right
now that you've looked at it it's so
easy okay but that brings us back now
okay but we can't take taking was played
in the game minute lost what happens on
King c7 and for you here it says X clam
leading you to believe that black
doesn't lose King takes pawn yes
excellent excellent move okay now
something we wait and there's two real
ideas here for white rook g5 seems to be
one of the most straightforward moves
also we can run our King around we have
a couple different options here if g5
check again now we can take and this is
actually a draw if you know your king
and rook endings so slightly more
entertaining is if they go back with the
intention of running to h3 now black has
to sort of wait until in this position
we can always meet this here with this
check and this would also be a draw so
White has some slight winning chances
well yeah it just goes back to this
decision right here and of course these
are hard to mean it's like well you got
50% chance if you just guessed
but these always requires some some
really serious calculation and
especially whenever you're trading the
very very last set of pieces you better
make sure that you're at least drawing
here and in this case you're not which
is very easy after you guys saw a couple
lines this is demonstrating the point
yeah so yeah you want to you want to
play like a computer in these end games
because they have a take back button and
real chess you know people don't give
you take back so often but that's a
that's hopefully some instructive and
game puzzles for you guys I hope you
guys did enjoy that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]